being a physicist from all objective  point of views is a miserable career the  only reason it's worth doing is you just  enjoy it is you're obsessed by it you  love what you're doing if you do it as a  job it's going to be very very  disappointing I think don't  underestimate yourself until I went on  this crazy adventure of Amanda and Ice  Cube I always live with the insecurity  that I didn't belong to the circles I  moved in which I think must be true for  almost every graduate student just get  over that I don't know how to do design  effort did it at many times of my career  I think I missed opportunities because I  was insecure it are not always the smart  people who made the breakthroughs that's  another way that's a very parochial way  of thinking about it imagination can  Trump intelligence that there are many  angles to doing research and so just go  for it